de tous les fichiers
liés aux événements que j'avais organisé
depuis j'étais dans la banque donc
j'étais là depuis huit ans ça
représentait entre je ne sais pas moi
700 et 1000 fichiers déjà c'est bon
qu'il était stocké où il commet qui
étaient stockés sur
[Musique]
moi je connais pas grand chose format
tic dans l'oval tactique
jamais accès un risque qui s'appelle
marketing donc c'était c'était à
l'intérieur du site est accessible par
chance pas trop 7 et 10 personnes et
certainement des gens l'informatique
est certainement par des gens en suisse
franchement
oui c'est à vous qu'on a demandé tout ça
c'est à moi qu'on a demandé sain et moi
je suis quelqu'un de
comment dire je suis comme les gens très
gentils gens très gentils sont en même
temps très affectif et moi en fait je
touche pas enfin je sais pas c'est comme
ce que je disais à vos collègues de la
relève et la peste l'autre jour c'est
comme si vous demandiez à un journaliste
de détruire tous ces articles de presse
depuis qui le journaliste ça n'a
absolument aucun sens donc moi j'ai
surtout senti comme on voulait
personnellement et qu'on voulait se
débarrasser de moi j'ai pas vu le
problème en fait le seuil est le
problème c'est moi et effectivement il
ya des problèmes relationnels avec cette
femme qui venait d'arriver et en gros on
m'a mis un peu ça sur le dos que en fait
j'avais voulu des promotions que les
avait pas eu que j'étais quelqu'un de
jaloux mois la jalousie c'est pas un
sentiment que je connais pas vraiment
non pas vraiment dans le cadre
professionnel non plus et et voilà ça
s'est envenimée puisque cette femme est
venue mais aussi me demander de détruire
mes archives papier et là je me suis dit
oh secours ça veut dire que j'ai plus
d'outils de travail
j'ai plus d'outils informatiques j'ai
plus d'outils qui me permettent de
continuer mon métier donc au delà de ma
personne c'est mon métier qui pose un
problème et donc voilà j'ai tiré un fil
j'essayais de comprendre pourquoi
j'étais un véritable problème dans dans
cette entreprise était claudie à l'oral
tout ça a bien évidemment je n'ai pas du
tout de mails ou de et c'est justement
ce que m'ont demandé les avocats c'est
ce que m'ont demandé un certain nombre
d'amis en dans fait en sorte d'avoir des
écrits de de cette demande de
destruction de fichiers bien évidemment
résultat des courses vous ne supprimez
rien non et je rencontre
puisque mon avantage est que j'avais été
recruté par ubs au moment où la banque
a été à créer une chaussure le micro
j'ouvre une parenthèse désolé en fait
j'ai été recruté par la banque quand
elle a ouvert en france parce qu'en
suisse la banque a un sens et des années
en france la filiale a été créée juste
avant à l'aube de l'an 2000 en 1999 donc
moi j'avais été recruté à l'époque où
c'était une start up de 40 personnes et
du coup je connaissais tout le monde
j'ai vu tous les gens arrivent et les
bureaux de province ouvrir donc tous les
recrutements et tous les collaborateurs
passer obligatoirement par voilà par mon
bureau à un moment donné pour avoir des
brochures pour parler aux médias pour
les publicités pour les événements enfin
voilà tout ce qu'on voulait et donc
j'avais un certain nombre de contacts
dans cette banque qui était ce qu'on
appelle des clients internes
et je me suis rapproché de certains
d'entre eux mais je comprends pas je
comprends pas ce qu'on me
et là j'ai eu des réponses qui m'ont
kimmons tétanisés mais vraiment c'est à
dire que les banquiers qui avaient des
problèmes avec leur propre hiérarchie et
comme il ya jamais de hasard leur propre
hiérarchie c'était aussi le fameux
directeur général dont le bureau a été
perquisitionné
mme apprennent qu on leur demande de
travailler main dans la main avec les
banquiers suisses oui comme moi je
équipes marketing de suisse jusque là je
voyais pas le problème et eux
m'apprennent qu'en fait
ces gens là n'ont pas le droit de
travailler en france puisqu'ils n'ont
pas s'appelle techniquement de cartes de
démarchage ils ne peuvent pas être
banquier sur notre territoire puisque
vente des produits donc des produits
suisses des produits ce qu'on n'a pas
l'offre or
c'est interdit c'est interdit dans notre
pays hélas si vous voulez c'est un
véritable tsunami pas ce que vous dites
mais pour qu'on l'a jamais su en tout
cas moi mon niveau puisque je n'étais
pas du tout dans les opérations de la
banque j'ai jamais été formés à quoi que
ce soit
et puis une fois qu'on l'a dit qu'est ce
qu'on risque c'est à dire que moi je me
retrouve au milieu d'un truc auquel je
comprends strictement rien à l'époque je
sais juste qu'on me demande de détruire
mes données comme si je n'avais jamais
travaillé là
et puis vous contacter le pouvoir
français non ça se passe pas comme ça
c'est à dire que j'étais élu des
collaborateurs rens il s'appelle
en terme technique j'étais secrétaire du
comité d'hygiène de sécurité et des
conditions de travail
donc à ce moment là bas c'est à dire
vous défendez l'épreuve de harcèlement
alors il n'ya pas lisse 13 de pression
voilà mauvaise pioche
exactement et donc
je suis allé voir l'inspection du
travail parce qu'après avoir posé des
questions en réunion sur la destruction
de données sur le turnover des
collaborateurs sur un certain nombre de
choses
comme l'aja vu comme vous voulez
vraiment je me suis tourné vers le
ministère du travail on verra bien qui
m'a dit très clairement la mj beau vous
êtes salarié protégé continue et voyez
avec vos collègues au cee et au chsct et
puis là ça a été
un deuxième effet kiss cool c'est à dire
personne
personne c'est à dire que
jamais on m'a parlé de jammeh qui que ce
soit d'autre que moi en 2008 2009 dans
les dents les élus ont pu parler dans
ces réunions de ce que je viens de vous
dire c'est à dire du démarchage
illicite de pratiques offshore de
l'évasion fiscales de blanchiment de
capitaux de tous qui défraye la
chronique depuis quelques années
j'imagine que vous avez forcément
entendu parler des autres affaires
bancaires l'a récemment scellé malta à
malta files c'est lé football x tout
l'hiver
les panneaux maple l'année dernière donc
et à chaque fois ubs est cité en plus ce
qui est complètement incroyable donc en
fait vous êtes dans la banque de gestion
de fortune la plus ancienne au monde qui
a la meilleure des réputations puisque
vous savez les banques c'est un peu
comme les césar les oscars pour les pour
les
la profession du showbiz c'est à dire
que tous les ans il ya un classement des
banques et ubs a toujours été
la première banque au monde par ce
classement yoman a donc noté par ses
pairs sur le thème de performance tout
ce que vous voulez
donc c'est un peu comme si vous étiez
barnier à quelqu'un et que d'un coup
vous appreniez le côté
l'autre côté de cette personne dire que
pour moi c'était mais vraiment d'une
violence inouïe vous étiez jamais posé
la question comment une banque qui
arrivait à faire de l'argent mais moi je
travaillais à la communication de la
banque donc à partir non vous êtes
toujours en lien avec le président le
directeur général qui vous dit nous on
fait tout en fonction de les autorités
de contrôle et de toute la législation
française qu'est ce que vous allez
remettre en question la parole de gens
qui sont vos dirigeants et qui en plus
vous explique le droit bancaire puisque
moi c'est pas du tout mon métier moi
j'ai fait mon métier qu'ils aiment et et
de représentation comme n'importe quelle
fille ou ce sont des métiers féminins
comme n'importe quelle personne que je
pouvais rencontrer à roland-garros au
stade de france dans un opéra c'est à
dire que vous êtes là finiront
représenter une marque n'y a pas deux
comme on appelait ça déjà deux théories
des baïonnettes intelligente dans la
communication
c'était bien je vous êtes en train de me
dire que j'étais très stupide non non
non les théories des baïonnettes
intelligente vous connaissez cette
théorie là c'est quand un policier
reçoit un ordre qui n'est pas ou qui
fait défaut par rapport à ses valeurs
ils ne l'appliquent pas donc j'ai été
une baïonnette atténuantes à ce moment
là en 2008 c'est ce que vous êtes en
train de dire un peu stupide cesa
moi je n'ai pas exécuté cet ordre parce
que je suis quelqu'un de
d'affectif et je me suis dit un truc qui
va pas je ne comprends pas et quand je
ne comprends pas c'est peut-être un
défaut de personnalité mais je bloque je
ne fais pas les choses parce qu'il faut
les faire comment comment le pouvoir
français s'est emparé de ce dossier là
mais alors attendez parce que c'est un
truc c'est les poupées russes a donc
acteur je parle à toutes ces hiérarchies
parce que moi je me demande ce qui se
passe quand même en étant mais où est ma
responsabilité maintenant que je sais
deuxièmement je suis élu j'en parle en
rayon les choses s'enveniment j'en parle
à l'inspection du travail qui vous êtes
là pour on est là pour vous protéger et
continuer puis quelques mois après
l'audi porter plainte quand votre
employeur donc je remplis une plainte
que jamais
souligne de la cité et passe comme ça en
2009 et puis moi je me dis mais la
justice doit faire son travail je vais
te trouver immédiatement et puis
terminez moi ma vie va reprendre c'est
la première fois que vous aviez à fuir
la justice a de ma vie oui est ce que
j'ai dit aux é tout de suite j'ai dit au
procureur de meaux galles eric de
montgolfier qui a beaucoup ri qui est
directement pour un coude pour un coup
d'essai c'est un coup très rude
un point coup de maître mais en tout cas
c'est pas la moindre des choses c'est à
dire que là vous rentrez dans un monde
en tant que citoyen ce que problème
aujourd'hui - ubs a priori je vais le
mettre au conditionnel pour qu'on évite
une fois de plus une diffamation mais
à frauder donc le problème aujourd'hui
inconditionnels
oreilles c'est très bizarre de dire ça
parce que sinon pourquoi on en veut
autant nous nous veut savoir que vous
avez fait remporter 13 milliards à 12
ans à monsieur sapin
alors on sait qu'il remplace
monsieur le
bourreau dans les moeurs boulou mais je
crois qu'un remaniement
incessamment sous peu voilà dire je sais
pas si c'est donc michel sapin entre
autres mais avant michel sapin monsieur
woerth eric là vous avez eu des contacts
avec macro un peu non je lui ai écrit
l'année dernière il a répondu
au moment où à bercy en tant que
ministre jay il mentait son mouvement en
marche qui n'était pas un parti
politique je l'étais déjà quand il était
encore ministre monte son ballon c'était
le squale 6 avril l'année dernière vont
le 6 mars l'année dernière et pour lui
expliquer à la fois ma situation mais
aussi pour lui parler de cette loi de
protection des lanceurs d'alerté et
et des déclarations de monsieur sapin
qui disait qu'il était le ministre des
finances qui lutter contre la fraude le
ministre aussi qu'ils voulaient avoir
cette loi qui porte son nom pour
défendre les lanceurs d'alert
et moi qui suis à la fois lanceur d
alerte dans la finance
monsieur sapin ne disait pas pouvoir
trouver d'issue à mon dossier
donc
j'ai réécrit justement monsieur macron
président de la république hier matin
pour lui dire je sais pas si vous
souvenez je vous ai écrit un peu plus
d'un an vous lanciez ce mouvement
politique félicite aujourd'hui de la
brillante carrière que vous avez
concrètement
concrètement que se passe-t-il pour les
lanceurs d'alerté en france aujourd'hui
alors
c'est abracadabrant c'est à dire que en
je suis toujours dans cette banque si on
fait un rétropédalage 2008 je dénonce en
interne 2009 je porte plainte contre la
banque il se passe rien pendant deux ans
et puis en 2011 j'ai déjà assermentés
qui viennent me voir et qui me dise
madame jybo on va vous suivre pendant
quinze jours avec des équipes des
caméras donc pendant quinze jours c'est
pendant le tournoi de tennis de roland
garros qu'elle dut tous les ans à la
même période dernières semaines de mes
premières semaines devant moi je leur
dis mais enfin j'ai rien fait quoi j'ai
justement dénoncée en interne jeu
surtout j'étais terrorisée et me disent
oui oui nous savons très bien que vous
n'avez pas voulu souscrire
mais la fraude continue chez ubs et là
c'est pas du conditionnel en 2011 en mai
ces personnes me disent ah c'était ça je
suis convoqué pour une première audition
qui dure
10h02 mémoire et puis je suis
régulièrement convoqué
jusqu'à l'été 2012 et à chaque fois je
suis convoqué à leur demande bien
évidemment dans leurs locaux qu'il était
à l'époque à vincennes pour leur donner
des informations sur un certain nombre
de
dossiers
voilà sur des procédures sur des clients
et aussi pour leur donner des
informations qui n'étaient pas forcément
dans mon périmètre professionnelle
parce que j'ai oublié de vous dire qu'en
2009 donc deux ans avant ubs a fait un
plan social 200 personnes dans lequel
j'étais censé
disparaître et que cette même inspection
du travail qui m'a demandé de porter
plainte contre la banque a validé
le licenciement la demande de
licenciement de 99 de mes collègues
à l'exception du mien donc on m'a laissé
à l'intérieur d'une entreprise qui
fraude dont j'ai dénoncé les fraudes en
gros vous a laissé comme indique dans
une boîte et on vous en dépression on
vous a pas donné un radis pour encaisser
en plus de votre serveur non et
aujourd'hui
j'ai un avocat alors qu'il paye qui
n'est pas david koubbi mais un autre
avocat qui est spécialisée en procédure
administrative qui a écrit plusieurs
fois au nouveau directeur des douanes
qui est à bercy depuis le mois de
février
donc ce monsieur quand il est arrivé on
lui a dit quand même qu'il ya un
véritable problème dans mon dossier
c'est à dire que l'état ne reconnaissent
pas le travail que j'ai fait pour lui et
puis surtout qui m'a mise en risque à ce
point j'aurais dû être protégé et
la réponse est aussi courage fillon
c'était dur que nous estime qu' aucun
souci dans votre dossier quand monsieur
macron a été élu il ya un mois mon
avocat a réécrit en disant écoutez
maintenant on va faire un communiqué de
presse puisque on veut vous attaquer aux
tribunaux administratifs madame djibo
vous auriez dû la rémunérer vous auriez
dû la dédommager des services qu'elle
vous a rendu et en une réponse c'est
assez édifiante ce monsieur a pris son
téléphone le directeur des douanes pour
dire écoutez enlevé mon nom du
communiqué de presse
soit et puis ce n'est pas les douanes
qui sont en faute c'est l'état français
voilà j'ai pas eu de loi qui a été passé
récemment sur leur rémunération et la
protection des indics
wiki est passé l'un et c'est à l'essai
pour deux ans alors avant que vous ayez
des messages qui disent délation
tout ce qu'on veut c'est quand même très
encadrée c'est à dire ce sont des cas de
fraude internationale on vient de parler
des malts apple c'est mal tu as far as
they football league c'est à dire des
systèmes organisés évasion fiscale on
parle pas du voisin qui est enterrée
quelque chose dans son jardin
et donc les 13 milliards ils ont
récupéré comment comment ils ont fait ce
petit conte alors il ya plusieurs choses
moi je ne sais pas si j'ai le droit de
parler de l'avocat n'est pas là donc le
budget vous donc
il ya eu des récupérations d'un certain
nombre de données dire ça comme ça je ne
sais pas comment autrement que je peux
vous le dire pour encore éviter une
diffamation de la banque qui dirait que
mais là comme est là
traîner des journalistes semaine
dernière j'ai plusieurs noms en
diffamation parce qu'elle disait que
leurs propos et est une entrave au
secret de l'instruction quand même dire
la l'instruction est terminée mais bon
on va prendre notre sujet maintenant on
est en 2017 vous gagnez votre vie
comment je ne gagne plus ma vie depuis
que j'étais licencié par ubs le 10
février 2012 vous avez des aides
sociales oui
450 euros par mois vous touchez des sous
avec des livres
j'ai vendu 5000
sait combien ces 20 20 centimes le livre
c'est ça vous touche et même pas oui
c'est à dire j'avais eu un avaloir en
2014 comme mon livre était sorti il est
que la valoir il est toujours pas
complété donc donc non c'était surtout
un outil pour dire un
1 ce qui s'était passé vraiment
parce que c'est quand même intéressant
d'aller voir que ces techniques de
harcèlement j'ai quand même été reconnue
en tout cas en justice pour avoir été
harcelée par mon employeur et on voit
aujourd'hui que ces techniques de
harcèlement sont relativement fréquentes
dans les grandes entreprises ont touché
la sécurité sociale
rien moi j'ai été reçu quand j'avais été
en arrêt maladie en 2009 par la sécurité
sociale
voilà qui ne la doit la loi sapin est ce
que ça a changé quelque chose
la changer pour qui pour vous alors pour
moi et pour les autres lanceurs dallaire
ski son lanceur d' alerte depuis des
années ça ne change absolument rien
puisque la loi n'est pas rétroactive
points
a priori ce qui serait lanceur d alerte
à partir d'aujourd'hui et si vous
regardez comment fonctionne cette loi
sapin il faut aller voir le n + 1 la une
+ 2 la direction si ça bouge pas c'est
exactement ce qui m'est arrivé et j'ai
assez répété un aux médias que c'est se
jeter dans la gueule du loup
se fait exprès
écoutez j'ai été entendue en avril
l'année dernière par le rapporteur en
lui disant que c'est une ineptie de
d'avoir rapporté à sa direction regardez
moi c'est ma supérieure hiérarchique qui
me demande de détruire des données suite
à une perquisition ça veut bien dire que
toute la hiérarchie est au courant pour
moi il y avait deux ou trois choses
importantes séquelles alertes soient
externes c'est-à-dire houllier pas
d'intrusion dans des systèmes
informatiques de l'entreprise
imaginez quelqu'un en fait je sais pas
vous êtes forcément plus au fait comment
là dessus mais une adresse ip qui envoie
un truc en disant bon ça va pas bien et
ça forcément de qui est derrière
l'ordinateur donc un il fallut une
alerte externe et mon avis or tout le
monde ne partage pas mais c'est la
responsabilité des élus qui sont élus un
peu comme nos sénateurs et nos députés
pour nous représenter alors représenter
les collaborateurs des entreprises et
c'est eux qui quelque part doivent aller
aux alleuds au frontal avec les
directoire les directeurs des directions
des entreprises demander des audits
externes etc pour savoir si
effectivement on a affaire à des
affabulateurs ou si c'est pratique
dysfonctionnements existent vraiment
vous avez pas fait ça pour le fric ah
ben je suis aux minima sociaux depuis le
1er juillet 2014 ça fait trois ans
vous conseillez con si l'on vous dit un
futur lanceur d alerte de le devenir ou
peint en france
alors en l'occurrence en france à lui
c'est très complexe c'est à dire que
tout ça c'est un problème de conscience
moi j'ai répété ce très souvent que se
taire c'est encourager le crime moi tant
que je ne savais pas qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que j'aille dénoncé quelque chose
que j'ignore partir du moment où
j'apprends que je travaille dans une
entreprise qui m a mise en risque qui
s'est complètement foutu de moi ou
conditionnés au conditionnel
qui semblerait être sûrs de nos deux
fisc la preuve ça c'est monsieur
monsieur lapin des 12 milliards entre
entre 2004 et 2008 c'est dixit notre ex
miss des finances donc là je
n'interviens pas dans les propos de
monsieur sapin
je fais que les répéter
mais qu'est ce que vous faites un voeu
c'est juste un problème de conscience
donc conseillé à des lanceurs de l'air
d'être lanceur d alerte a priori
aujourd'hui ils devraient être protégés
c'est à dire qu'une fois qu'ils en ont
parlé à leur hiérarchie etc ils peuvent
plus y penser tiens c'est comme moi
voyez on m'a laissé pourrir dans une
entreprise qui
aurait fraudé
il ya quand même un rapport de confiance
dans une entreprise vous apprenez quelle
fraude vous rester dans l'entreprise je
sais pas rien pour moi il ya vérité une
véritable véritable problème donc
qu'est-ce que je conseillerai
il existe des choses aujourd'hui
qu'il n'existait pas quand nous en 2008
on est tombé dans cette marmite
lanceur d' alerte
sans savoir que c'est un mot qui
existait sans savoir que nous n'aurions
pas été protégé par l'état nous avons
aidé
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il ya des tonnes de
possibilité de transmettre des données
de manière on va faire plus simple
et céline me dissuader d'être lanceurs
d'alerté avec votre expérience
enfin en vue des taux minima sociaux
c'est-à-dire sans travail ce que le
monde du travail à partir du moment où
votre visage et votre nom est connu
c'est juste impossible donc c'est la
mort c'est une mort sociale c'est à dire
qu'on vous met pas un flingue sur la
tête et vous disparaissez dans une
flaque d'eau c'est de toute façon ça
resserrer les liens familiaux d'autres
lanceurs d'alerté écoutez moi je n'ai
plus de maison depuis le mois de janvier
donc je vois plus mes enfants
enfin voila c'est des situations d'une
complexité absolue avec des procès qui
ne termine pas j'étais en justice en
2010 ou en plus la justice m'a donné
raison en diffamation
j'étais en procès en 2015 la justice m'a
aussi donné raison sur le harcèlement en
compte la banque en revanche j'ai pas
été entendu par la juge d'instruction
grosse affaire pénale aujourd'hui mon
livre est attaqué celui dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure un acquis par une
baisse en dix ans contre
le harcèlement n'a jamais le titre du
livre à la femme car ça fait vraiment
trop et donc ils attaquent pourquoi pour
le harcèlement ni ce que le harcèlement
n'a jamais existé chez ubs alors que
j'étais justement j'ai un jugement qui
n'a pas été frappé d'appel là-dessus
disent que le démarchage des banquiers
suisses sur le territoire français n'a
jamais existé alors qu'ils sont mis en
examen pour blanchiment aggravé de
fraude fiscale et qu'en parallèle à ça
on a le ministère des finances qui
disent elle nous a aidés pendant plus
d'un an et on estime que c'est entre
quatre d'entre entre 2004 et 2008 12
milliards d'euros mais alors où est
l'état par rapport à ses procès il
aurait dû empêcher la diffamation par
définition
[Musique]
c'est de l'incompétence ils ont peur que
ça généralise les lanceurs d'alerté
c'est quoi votre interprète qu'après
plusieurs fois aux ja ça à la fois c'est
l'inertie de de l'appareil d'état c'est
quoi c'est le fait que tout le monde
garde son petit emploi sont petites
tempêtes fonctionnaires personne ne veut
faire des vagues on a on passe le temps
qu'on a attiré dans la fonction publique
on prend sa petite retraite on achète sa
petite maison et puis on se cache on
regarde la télé c'est ça alors là je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord parce que
je pense pas que c'est les petits
fonctionnaires oui je que des rémy
garnier le fonctionnaire du ministre du
mystère des des finances qui avait
caricaturé l'un des sens d'écouté je
connais rémy garnier et donc je peux
vous parler c'est rémi garde ne vais pas
vous parler de de gens que je ne connais
pas
qui était quelqu'un de respecté dans sa
fonction et c'est à partir du moment où
il ya des informations sur un élu qui
s'appelle à l'époque monsieur cahuzac
est juste
juste et un élu s'est fait plaqué or ici
voilà un placard teasé bâton il ya eu
des plaintes au tribunal administratif
en quantité alors peut-être pas autant
que denis robert mais en tout cas en
tout cas ça a été très violent
[Musique]
les gens font leur travail c'est
toujours au dessus où ça coince moi qui
aujourd'hui may cry en disant qu'on peut
rien faire pour moi c'est quand même
directeur des douanes qui dépendent
directement du ministre des fiances qui
disait sur un plateau télé face à moi
ils face à un visuel c'est que vous avez
reçus ici qui peut rien faire pour moi
c'est michel sapin ministre des finances
alors donc d'un côté vous avez un
ministre du budget qui lutte contre la
fraude fiscale et qui fraudent le fisc
grâce à ubs parce que vous voyez c'est
quand même la même affaire en tout cas
les deux pendant d'une même affaire
z'avez monsieur woerth
qui était impliqué dans la ferme est en
cours et qui s'en est sorti avec un
non-lieu bon sauveur tant l'a jamais
entendue dans le dossier la défense des
lanceurs dallaire du dossier ubs
monsieur moscovici a nommé à la
commission des sanctions de l'amf donc
l'autorité des marchés financiers la
déontologue du bs alors qu ubs étaient
déjà mises en examen et puis après on à
monsieur monsieur sapin qui nous dit
être incompétent sur mon dossier
donc où ils se renvoient tous la balle
façon administrations les astérix et
obélix
en maintenant qu'on a fait le tour de
cette inertie les français quand ils
vous croiser ce qui vous reconnaissent
est ce que quand vous êtes
dans un cercle qui n'a pas l'habitude de
traiter ce genre d'affairé skull les
gens commencent à s'en emparer ils s'en
foutent c'est con qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
alors suis très surprise justement de
[Musique]
cotisation ça a changé quelque chose oui
il ya quand même quelques milliers de
personnes qui me connaissent mais les
gens qui me connaissent ce sont les
associations ce sont les citoyens
engagés ce sont des gens comme david
koubbi elise lucet et pour ne citer
qu'eux qui sont justement des porte
paroles
qui mute contre la corruption qui
veulent plus qu'on leur tape c'est tout
les listes du seuil journaliste fait son
travail de sa vie koubbi l'avocat
chacun chacun joue son rôle est-ce que
vous pensez que les avocats des
journalistes ont pu correctement leur
boulot alors écoutez je suis en train
d'écrire un livre là qui va aider écrit
qui va sortir à la rentrée où je parle
justement de la responsabilité de tous
ceux qui auraient dû être là à nos côtés
pour nous défendre parce que aujourd'hui
on est justement connu ou reconnu j'aime
pas trop reconnu en tout cas
ceux qui s'intéressent à à l'éthique la
transparence intégrité ne peuvent que
connaître le travail des danseurs d'
alerte en france et à l'international et
en même temps
et je le vois tous les jours le mot
lanceur d' alerte
ça commence à parler à ceux qui sont en
terminale ou qui sont étudiants c'est à
dire que grâce à certains profs éveillé
c'était sujet de tpe notamment au
terminal donc là j'interviens où les
écoles de communication les écoles de
journalisme lanceurs d'alertés y est
c'est rentrer dans leur culture mais
sinon les autres
pour croiser les gens dans la rue
quand je discute avec les gens ils n'ont
jamais entendu parler alors si je dis qu
à usak ça ça parle
lanceur dallaire non je suis même très
surprise et là vraiment c'est un appel
que je peux lancer à tous ceux qui nous
écoutent mois pour essayer de survivre
j'ai donné des cours d'anglais parce que
je suis à moitié anglo saxon et les
gamins qui ont 18 19 ans je leur parle
des lois de sonars de l'année dieu lune
assange
9 sur 10 ne savent pas qu'ils sont alors
qu'ils sont sur youtube tout le temps
mais ça c'est très choquant par contre
en
- les enfants c'est en a bien d'autres
qui connaissent et aiment bien c'est
dommage que vous ouvrez une parenthèse
on a besoin de quelqu'un qui parle
anglais un regret oui oratoire pour
faire une petite interview un peu on
peut vous emmener
on va les voir quelqu'un
on or pas là revenons à notre sujet nord
aussi aux gardes hockey et donc le
jeu prend que je crois qu'il va traîner
en plus dans votre dernier bouquin
non
il ya trois surprises allez jamais connu
une 2000
je vous laisse enchaîné avant je ne sais
plus où on en était surprise dans le
livre ah non la surprise annoncée en
séance ne sont pas des surprises
d'accord on passe à autre chose à
vous en tant que lanceur d'un verte vous
avez des enfants quand vous entendez les
jeunes en terminale ou à 9 sur 10 ne
connaissent pas julian assange doit ce
modèle vous dites pas que en fait on vit
dans un monde qui va trop vite
que vous avez gâché votre vie pour rien
et que vous auriez mieux fait de vous
conformer dans le stéréotype même de
quelqu'un qui ne bouge pas les vagues on
revient à ce qu'on disait ya cinq
minutes c'est à dire tout ça c'est un
point de conscience d'un problème
d'éducation c'est un problème de colonne
vertébrale
moi je n'aurais pas pu me taire et
aujourd'hui quand on pose la question
mais c'était à refaire cette question
qui revient tout le temps un je reviens
pas sur le passé et puis de on est
soi-même ou on ne l'est pas moi jamais
demandé pourquoi j'avais quitté le monde
du football je travaillais avant on m'a
jamais demandé pourquoi j'ai vécu t j'ai
travaillé pendant très longtemps pour
des gens du moyen orient
personne n'a jamais posé ces questions
là
un
mois il ya des choses que je ne peux pas
voir
et quand je dis pas voir le terme est
pas bon c'est à dire ne peut pas
cautionner
point donc chacun agit avec sa
conscience donc si ces jeunes ne savent
aller sur youtube que pour regarder leur
chanteur comme les ondes est à l'orage
c'est très bien mais qu'en même temps il
n'est pas une envie s'informer alors
qu'aujourd'hui la vie ce sont les
réseaux les réseaux informatiques les
réseaux sociaux enfin quand même une
enfance très diffus nadeau l'essence est
très différente de la nôtre au niveau en
terme de communication ça ça me choque
parce que je me demande ce que leurs
parents ce dont il discute avec avec les
gens qui ont mon âge quand même et puis
quel âge
on ne demande jamais l'âge d'une femme
changeons de sujet
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la loi sur
le secret des affaires
eh bien écoutez j'en parle justement
dans ce prochain livre c'est à dire que
vous souvenez que en france elle devait
passer cette loi un début 2015 ou 2016
je sais plus et parfois même c'est une
question qui nous a été posée par notre
communauté en direct sur internet très
bien donc cette loi devait passer fait
pas monsieur macron qui devait faire
passer cette loi secret des affaires en
france et il ya eu un tollé à la fois
des journalistes des syndicats
d'associations et de lanceurs d alerte
dont je fais partie grâce à ce tollé
cette loi est passée à la trappe mais
elle est passée à bruxelles et donc
c'est pareil c'est encore un effet kiss
cool puisque la grande majorité de nos
députés européens ont voté cette loi
qui veut dire que on protège les
multinationales le secret secret dont on
peut comprendre qu'il ya des secrets de
fabrication etc il ya eu assez de
d'espionnage
mais enfin
le fait de faire passer cette loi avant
de protéger les citoyens aujourd'hui
c'est ça le problème c'est à dire qu'on
voit bien que les informations sont bien
plus protégés que les citoyens le secret
bancaire est fait pour ça il n'y a pas
que secret bancaire secret bancaire
secret des affaires tous ces secrets
sont là pour protéger l'information
voilà vous avez parlé de députation
d'europe on a
hésité à vous recevoir parce que vous
êtes engagés en politique auprès nicolas
dupont aignan et que je suis un soutien
à nicolas parce que c'est alors attendez
parce que ça si on commence comme ça ça
va pas ouais pas comprendre depuis dix
ans
dix ans moi je veux faire deux
quinquennats canam ce sarkozyste qui dit
les paradis fiscaux c'est fini
takeda monsieur hollande qui dit notre
adversaire c'est la finance si david
koubbi étaient à côté de loin je pense
que ou du goût denis robert dirait
françois hollande françois hollande je
reprends s'aime on n'en a rien à [__]
des paradis fiscaux il avait toute
latitude pour pouvoir opérer le jeu me
fait absolument
voilà avec jersey les bermudes le panama
qui ont été retirés ces dernières années
justement des paradis fiscaux et la
liste grise est noire des paradis
fiscaux
est donc nicolas dupont et donc nicolas
du voyant c'est le seul patron de party
parti quand même un paquet en france le
patron de partis qui met appelé en me
disant mais qu'est ce que c'est que
cette affaire comme comment allez vous
comment est ce qu'on peut faire pour
vous aider il travaillait en 2013 en
tant que député avec le sénateur avec le
député communiste alain bocquet
sur le carrousel tva donc 20 milliards
qui manquent au pays tous les ans et
voilà il a fait plusieurs choses et
qu'on l'a déjà il a
essayé d' interpeller françois hollande
par un certain nombre de courriers sur
ma situation on a écrit des tribunes à
la fois pour lutter contre la fraude
fiscale et pour protéger les lanceurs d
alerte autrement que par cette loi sapin
et puis en 2015 il m'a dit mais écoutez
ce serait bien que vous soyez tête de
liste à paris pour les régionales sa
tête de liste mais un jeu sur tout le
monde surtout pas prendre la place de
qui que ce soit et puis dauger jamais
fait de politique de ma vie et il m'a
dit vous faites une erreur grave ce que
vous faites c'est de la politique
voulait mettre de l'éthique et de
l'intégrité en finance c'est la même
chose que de le faire en politique
le alors là je vais avoir un point noir
mais le budget de l'ile-de-france et x
milliards parce que ces 6 milliards 14
milliards je sais plus beaucoup plus et
plus et déjà la communauté
d'agglomération disent ils veulent 200
chiffre pas loin du milliard n'empêche
alors ces 6 milliards je crois que non
donc ce serait bien qu'on aille voir où
on voit cet argent et ça c'est
absolument je suis complètement d'accord
donc on va te voilà on a surtout
travaillé comme ça moi je n'ai plus eu
pancartes et debout la france je n'ai
et gvt et comptons parfois on m'invite
mais c'est normal que les lanceurs des
lettres de lanceurs d alerte se politise
de plus en plus ouvertement bayonne
mais est-ce que c'est ce se politiser
ces faire passer un message a
justement aux médias qui laisse la
parole à cette occasion
l'un des exemples que je peux vous citer
c'est la france de la femme c'est pas
pour être pour ou contre la femme c'est
le jour du jour le jour ni deux le voilà
exactement mais bon ou à partie ce
moment là on peut parler de sujets qui
intéressent tout le monde d'autre que
moi j'ai l'impression que lanceur
dallaire c'est
c'est coluche qui disait ça on parle de
génération spontanée ben voilà on est on
est un truc là qui venons d'arriver et
puis après on se reproduit entre nous et
que on n'est pas comme les autres mais
on est des citoyens comme tout le monde
justement où on essaye d'élever les
enfants avec un certain nombre de
valeurs au sein de 2,2
communauté que ce soit à l'école que
soit le pays et c'est donc
en parler de manière publique
oui c'est à la fois un acte complètement
politique mais c'est pas politiser le
l'intégrité n'est pas de gauche ou de
droite si c'était à refaire parce que
vous lille tabriz relier votre sortie du
placard en tant que lanceur d'ailleurs
c'est à dire est ce que vous êtes dr
idée des mesures proactives de lanceurs
d'alerté c'est à dire chiffrer vos
documents passé sous le radar
d'avoir une optique nos petites beaucoup
de plus guerrière que la fleur au fusil
passez moi l'expression mais c'est pire
que ça à moi j'étais vous inviter à un
sinois rouages et est un cygne blanc une
colombe 1 c'est à dire que je n'y
comprenais absolument rien je ne savais
pas ah oui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui oui j'ai des connaissances
ne sera ce 4l et rencontrer dieu n'a
songé à l'ombre l'ambassade d'équateur
il ya deux ans il m'a donné quelques
petits conseils pour protéger justement
mes échanges informatiques parce que
j'ai des problèmes
techniques technologiques dans tous les
sens terrible
alors ça c'est une question qui vient
d'internet intentions snowdon à la nsa
virgule vous chez ubs virgules comment
on intègre des entreprises comme celle
là sans savoir qu'elles sont immorales
question internet 1 quelles sont
immorales alors si nous on ne l'avait
pas dit qu'il dirait
s'ils avaient passé un dunk pied sol
aujourd'hui alors il yad'autres 1 et à
d'autres lanceurs d'alerté américain jim
bunning
toy story
enfin si lui avait pas fait ces
révélations en 2013 qu'est-ce que vous
sauriez voilà
donc c'est bien gentil à chaque fois de
nous retourner le truc mais où sont les
autres chez ubs en france moi j'ai connu
à peu près 3000 collaborateurs avec le
turnover etc où sont les autres où sont
les banquiers fait sortir personne du
bois le fait que vous sacrifiez non il y
avait quelques collaborateurs qui
avaient leurs propres problèmes avec ubs
voilà alors soit ils ont négocié
souhaitons gagné aux prud'hommes et puis
et puis voilà au alors tiens je reviens
vous fait penser à ça
si on a bien une française qui est connu
dans son alerte c'est moi et en plus
aussi à l'international depuis que la
loi sapin est passé du passé 18 décembre
2016 ou 15 décembre 2016
j'ai reçu un courrier de bercy
en janvier chiemsee mais madame djibo
vous n'êtes pas lanceur d' alerte
vous êtes juste un témoin dans le
dossier ubs
donc c'est intéressant vous voyez la
sémantique et les comment disent les
intellectuels les éléments de langage ou
la prise de contrôle de la dialectique
ou si ça marche pas mal voyez donc la
norme pour éviter de qualifier ce que
vous êtes pour éviter de vous
reconnaitre mais alors attendez parce
que ça répond peut-être à la question de
cette personne c'est d'un côté donc une
loi de lanceurs d'alert pour nous
protéger parce qu'il faut absolument que
ces moutons à cinq pattes cette
génération spontanée le soir
qui s'engouffre immédiatement dans cet
espace que donne bercy ubs qui dit oh le
médian elle a usurpé son titre de l'an
seule alerte donc quand vous me demandez
tout à l'armée ce qui arrive derrière
mais ce qui arrive derrière c'est
attention avons pas croire que la
justice a été méchante avec nous bercy
était méchant et toc maintenant tout le
monde est gentil avec vous ça c'est donc
qui avant de sortir endurci c'est vous
oui et puis connaissais un peu justement
un certain nombre venaient nous voir
aussi et on vous donnera un certain
nombre de conseils qu'on peut pas donner
son téléphone portable sans rien voilà
l'avenir maintenant on fait quoi quand
on s'appelle stéphane riboud on pense à
la reconversion acheter un petit terrain
dans le larzac y élever des chèvres il
contemplait tel un cadavre passé sur un
fleuve alors je vais vous dire un truc
terrible parce que j'ai des enfants
quand une maman j'ai des enfants
j'étais à moscou cet hiver j'ai la
chance malgré ma situation de voyager
beaucoup vous êtes invités à gauche à
droite qu'à gauche à droite il ya qu aux
etats-unis où je mets plus les pieds moi
qui allais beaucoup aux états unis je
suis un petit peu parce que je pense que
mon soutient à 100 g snowdon pour être
complexe comme vous avez peur d'une
fouille au corps à la douane
oui ok me renvoie non premier avion ne
s'est pas je sais pas vos l'avion il ya
la fouille je sais pas on en parlait
tout à l'heure avec votre invité
précédent justement voilà pour savoir
et
est en fait qu'est-ce qu'on est quand on
est à l'étranger nous français
on représente un pays qui est sur sa
carte de visite
le pays des droits de l'homme et la
terre d'accueil le pays de l'intégration
le pays de la philosophe de la culture
des artistes de la liberté d'expression
oubliez y avait quatre millions de
personnes après charlie hebdo 1 rue de
paris et l'hexagone ya un an et demi
deux ans et demi
vous preniez une balle pour que les gens
sortent
dans la rue où ils s'emparent de ce
sujet là pourquoi vous avez pas fait une
grève de la faim
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas radicaliser
plus que ça je suis quand même
radicalisé et puisque l'un contre les
hommes politiques notamment je suis loin
d'être loin d'être sympa avec eux un si
moi je dis pas ce que je vous ai dit je
sais pas qui d'autre le 10 mai
françois hollande et nicolas sarkozy
sont deux exemples mais je vous ai cité
monsieur woerth monsieur cahuzac
monsieur moscovici ce sapin monsieur
macron enfin c'est à dire des hommes qui
sont au pouvoir et qu'ils ont et qu'ils
ont beaucoup de pouvoir justement donc
penser qu'ils ont beaucoup de pouvoir
écouter on a appris avec nos histoires
justement que
il était élu par des citoyens
mais qu'en fait ils sont là pour
défendre les intérêts des
multinationales
est ce que vous connaissez la notion
d'état profit
de quoi voulez-vous me faire parler
l'état profond c'est c'est un élément de
langage pour décrire ce qui tire
vraiment les ficelles pression mais
c'est ce dont ce à quoi j'ai découvert -
depuis cette sortie complètement
bengale et sans tomber dans les
stéréotypes machistes ou quoi que ce
soit heureusement que vous étiez pas
blonde parce que là c'était tout de
suite le stéréotype de la femme avec son
coeur ses valeurs qui pense
naturellement à les prévenir son état
qu'il ya un problème est que derrière
elle s'imaginait pas que l'état pouvait
être faillible sur sa démocratie sa
justice son appareil d'état
alors est-ce que vous tiendriez les
mêmes propos à irène frachon à antoine
deltour 1
1 tous ceux dont paraître en parler
voyez bien qu'on est très nombreux à
penser que l'état français alors je vous
parle justement cancon conçu à
l'étranger ce que les gens me renvoie de
la france
bon si à l'époque encore que l'état
était votre ami
si je vous réponds oui vous allez hurler
de rire mais riez je ne dis pas
parce que vous pensez que les lanceurs
d'alertés ont besoin de se rapprocher
des hackers radicaliser pour vous
endurcir des accords et radicalisée oui
d'aidé de thé surtout surtout
il ya que c'est une guerre d'information
aujourd'hui est-ce que celle ci bien
plus protégés que les citoyens donc
voilà parce que est-ce que vous avez
besoin d'aidé
moi à titre personnel
écoutez
il ya plusieurs choses le monde du
travail mais on a tourné le dos moi j'ai
plus de revenus donc il ya quelque chose
pour m'aider qui serait
un acte militant est un acte résistant
c'est d'acheter mon livre qui sort à la
rentrée parce que je parle de beaucoup
de gens vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup qui sont dans
des souffrances extrêmes parce qu'ils se
retrouvent eux aussi confrontés à la
justice au monde du travail aux médias
aux hommes politiques et leurs vies ont
été emportés moyer je tiens debout quand
même encore sur sortie les élèves qui
les tiennent très bien pouces comment
vous faites encore pour tenir debout
parce que vos perspectives sont fermés
c'est pas facile parfois je n'ai pas le
moral du tout j'ai des baisses de moral
et en fait je me rends compte
aujourd'hui
vous comprendrez 1 entre les lignes
c'est qu'en fait je ne suis pas seul
voilà j'ai toujours l'impression d'être
seuls partout face à une baisse
justice etc etc en fait on voit bien que
ces dernières trois quatre années trois
3 années
les chaussures sont organisés et on se
on se reconnaît
donc
je te vois on va bientôt sonner la fin
de la récré
parce qu'on commence à être un peu trop
nombreux c'est à dire que c'est bien
gentil d'avoir des politiques
complètement impuissant
des hommes impuissants qu'il dirige
c'est quand même très bizarre en tant
que femme oui
pendant je parle longuement comme vous
le disait mais de se rendre compte de ce
mépris
mépris j'ai eu le mépris des dirigeants
du ps je me disais c'est une exception
parce que c'est une banque suisse
c'est
véritablement un tsunami parce qu'en
fait on se retrouve complètement démunis
et la véritable guerre le véritable arme
et financière quand vous êtes une mère
de famille et que vous élever vos
enfants en plus sol
le seul revenu c'était c'est à dire ce
que j'avais dit à l'inspection du
travail qu'est ce que je vais faire
ensuite deux
de mon existence moi mon salaire c'est
mon seul revenu et puis en fait
j'ai peut-être eu aussi beaucoup de
chance dans ce parcours c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui mine de rien je suis
quand même reconnu par rapport à ce que
j'ai fait donc
le livre là qui va sortir et qui parle
des autres parce que j'estimais que
c'était très important de mettre de la
lumière sur ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
moyer suis lancé des alertes la plus
médiatisée et finalement personne ne me
connaît je prends le métro comme vous je
prends le bus comme tout le monde et on
me dis pas bravo c'est super machin les
gens sont déconnectés de ça mon envie de
vous le dire or c'est ainsi
oui mais ça me touche beaucoup parce que
toute cette génération et tous ceux qui
travaillent dans ses associés
association militante qui ont tous des
super idée pour eux je suis un peu là on
n'est pas grand mère sur une épaule it
on et vous n'êtes pas le grand rire pas
encore on voit simplement quelqu'un qui
se bat pour l'intérêt général simplement
qui parce qu il a reçues trop de cours
d'éducation civique quand il était petit
ou quand elle était petite oui et puis
les grands parents engagés des parents
stressent vous avez un esprit
français on esprit exactement et c'est
ça qui est reconnue à l'étranger c'est
pour ça qu'à l'étranger sont tous très
surpris de ma situation à moscou où
j'étais cet hiver sa première fois que
j'allais en russie moi j'ai plutôt
possibilité d'aller aux états unis
j'étais très surprise de l'accueil qui
m'a été réservé puisque tout le monde
toute la communauté franco francophone
parce qu'une situation comme la mienne
est impossible dans la pays et en russie
c'est peu c'est possible pour eux ou pas
est posé la question à d'autres qui
vivent en russie je ne réponds pas là où
je suis pas compétent temps à nous la
question l'ambassadeur de russie en
direct alors exactement donc en tout cas
aujourd'hui il faut trouver des
solutions
puisqu'ils ne l'ont pas tué puisqu'on
est encore là et qu'on a la parole ça
qui est important parce que tout ce dont
je parle dans mon livre parce que vous
avez l'oreille vous avez la parole mais
est-ce que vous avez l'oreille pour
déclencher une masse inertielle
suffisamment importante pour prendre le
pouvoir politique à la gorge pour faire
appliquer notre constitution
et pourquoi moi et pourquoi moi tout ça
là attention il ya
ce que j'ai toujours dit depuis trois
ans pour qu'on puisse avancer il faut
qu'il ya une solidarité entre les
inserts d'alert mais la solidarité doit
pas être qu'en france elle doit aussi à
l'international
c'est aussi pour ça que tu allais en
italie le mois dernier pour que on parle
et moi en tant que française et j'ai pas
dur dit moi je mets en tout cas en tant
que française avec cette loi sapin
aujourd'hui qui vaut ce qu'elle vaut on
est d'accord c'est une première marche
sur laquelle il va falloir construire en
italie z'ont rien donc les lanceurs
dallaire sont traités comme moi
aujourd'hui on va après
continuez on a essayé de matraques et
sur les réseaux sociaux qu'il fallait
que les eurodéputés qui sont en train a
priori de passer une loi pour protéger
lanceur d alerte en europe
auditionne des lanceurs d alerte
mais non on les voit sur les réseaux
sociaux les uns après les autres les
irlandais et en parlant de d'irlande et
le député irlandais qui a fait un speech
de comment envoyer ouais c'est vrai la
guitare vous l'avez vu passer qu'est ce
qu'ils disaient
et d un truc extraordinaire et 10 en
fait que sur tout faux pas de lancer en
alerte et surtout il faut rien dire
parce que c'est la mort assurée voyez je
ne suis pas irlandaise malgré ma couleur
de cheveux mais
effet
certaines associations que je ne citerai
pas ici pour m'éviter des problèmes
qui font des colloques pour parler de
protection des lanceurs d'alert
notamment en europe disent quoi son pays
pour qui deux ans mais ça c'est une
vraie question a priori on a beaucoup de
nos ex employeur qui sont des sponsors
des
adorables contributeurs de l'auteur
exactement
attendez moi est coupée et donc qui
disent que l'irlande et le pays en
europe qui protège le mieux les lanceurs
d alerte alors quand vous avez ce
monsieur on ne connaît ni d'ève ni
d'adam qui vous dit c'est la mort
assurée vous imaginez chez nous on vous
imagine en italie vous imaginez en
espagne en allemagne en allemagne en
parle jamais de l'allemagne et des
lanceurs d'alerté allemand c'est voilà
on est tous avec une corde au cou et on
attend tranquillement qu'on disparaisse
question d'internet selon vous le peuple
des pins s'est engagée ou celle élites
politiques et financières qui ne cache
trop bien les choses pour noter olution
ces deux mondes différents moi j'ai pu
avoir accès au sénat en 2012 j'ai mis
les pieds pour la première fois de ma
vie au sénat c'est beau bonnet continue
à oui j'ai déjeuné trois fois 6-1
absolument avec des
commandes hier des messieurs un peu
comme andy ventripotent et
des groupes voilà c'est déconnecté de la
réalité
comment ces gens là peuvent t'ils alors
qu'ils sont
élus
représenter le peuple les citoyens que
nous sommes vous voyez c'est pas une
question d'être de droite ou de gauche
c'est une question de se dire mais
comment ces gens là peuvent ils être
aussi loin
alors on a l'habitude sur dans les
communautés de surtout sur facebook
d'échangés autour de ces notions là il
ya un problème qui existe c'est à ces
politiques qui leur crève les yeux ou à
ces foules aveugle vous êtes dans quel
camp vous pensez qu'il ya possibilité
d'avoir un corps entre les deux est-ce
que des foules sont trop aveugle ou est
ce que ce sont les politiques qui leur
crachent trop les yeux bien évidemment
les gens sont capables
consenti pas consenti je pense qu'ils ne
se sentent pas concernés
c'est à dire que pour eux c'est une
élite ce terme élites politiques moi ça
me fait rire mais c'est déconnecté de
leur quotidien j'ai au quotidien ils
vont bosser on et prendre de transport
dont les problèmes leurs enfants ayant
des problèmes pour payer les factures
sont disputés avec le voisin avec la
belle-mère donc ils sont dans des
problèmes terre à terre tout ça pour eux
c'est lunaire et je pense que c'est
surtout le cas depuis une trentaine
d'années
puisque depuis les années soixante dix
les budgets de l'éducation nationale
dont qui suit fille d'enseignante petite
fille d'enseignants
l'école qui était un lieu de
de réflexion par rapport à cette
citoyenneté par rapport au civisme par
rapport aux élus
aujourd'hui c'est
c'est très loin de tout le monde
vraiment très loin de tout le monde
et on le voit avec l'abstention
c'était quoi 58% et
beaucoup plus de 50% voilà donc des 17
millions d'électeurs qui sont évaporés
entre la présidentielle de députation
on arrive à la fin de notre interview
déjà mais je pensais que vous allez me
garder tellement longtemps que j'ai beau
dehors déjà un
plaisir merci de votre invitation on
peut rester encore si c'est pas ça
dépend si vous avez des questions mois
s'était encore des questions on s'essuie
moi je voulais vous parler de deux
choses voyez comme on parle d'éducation
et sans être moraliste parce qu'on nous
dit souvent wing vous les lanceurs
d'alert des puristes sont des moralistes
et pas du tout en train de parler de
morale on parle d'éthique d'intégrité de
plus de transparence et je sais pas si
vous avez vu le documentaire café flore
vasseur cbl meeting snowdon moi j'ai eu
l'avantagé d'être invité à
l'avant-première donc j'ai pu assister
aux débats avec l'art et la sig qui est
professeur de droit à harvard et
quand on parle de démocratie
birgitta jonsdottir
voilà comme je sais pas prononcer son
nom je préfère ça aux militants du parti
pirate voilà on se rendent bien compte
qu'en fait ce qui se passe ici
dans le pays des droits de l'homme soit
c'est un terrain ça se passe partout
dans un système qui craint la crise la
récession c'est la faute des pauvres
c'est la faute de la classe moyenne il
ya une dette qu'il faut rembourser que
personne n'a voulu rembourser
quand on voit ce qui se passe en grèce
on se dit que peut-être demain nous
serons peuple grec mais les italiens se
disent la même chose donc
et ça répond aussi à
la question précédente c'est à dire que
les citoyens se sont complètement
déconnectés
non représentés c'est une cata tony
émotionnel ou c'est une démission
[Musique]
mais je pense que rien n'est blanc noir
c'est à dire vous voyez bien c'est un
type en six mois le est ce que est ce
que les gens vont pour parler
trivialement ils ont plein de q où ils
sont stressés de la crise qui arrive de
la paupérisation de la classe moyenne de
la gréce isation de la france
est ce que est ce que ça allait mais pas
dans une capacité de ne plus ressentir
ce qui se passe c'est depuis identifier
les priorités
une fois de plus je pense qu'il n'y a
pas qu'une seule chose je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ne s'y intéressent
ça m'intéresse pas de manière égoïste
c'est donc j'ai mon salaire tout va bien
je paye mes vacances ma voiture ma
maison tu heures donc pour une grosse
majorité de la population et c'est ce
que je voulais vous dire sur la ls etc
c'est-à-dire la conclusion du débat
qu'on a eue après médine snowdon c'était
quoi c'est de dire que finalement si des
histoires comme les miennes vous êtes 19
millions de foyers fiscaux vous êtes 36
millions de contribuables je ramène 12
milliards à l'état ça devrait vous
parler parce que ça fait 600 euros par
contribuable vous pouvez tous allés voir
michel sapin ou son remplaçant et dire
grâce à stéphanie ribot point nous
rendre 600 euros ça n'intéresse personne
nous sommes inaudible c'est ce que j'ai
dit à david l'autre jour donc il va
falloir passer à d'autres types
d'actions mais des actions non violentes
parce que et tagué une agence de la
société générale ou attaquer la taille
et la porte du ps ça peut se retourner
contre nous et puis deux se fait pas
avancer le débat
et prendre en otage un leader
ça fait avancer les choses ou pas
mais prendre quelqu'un d'acheter un acte
violent non qui doit être mon avis qu
est-ce que pour vous l'état est toujours
détenteur de la violence légitime
encore d'une violence attendait prenez
ma vie qu'il n'est plus une vie
ce que vous me disiez tout à l'heure moi
je devrais plus être là aujourd'hui avec
ce qu'on a fait est ce qu'on continue de
le faire parce que parce qu'on voit pas
la fin le procès ubs aura t'il mieux
qui sait
aura-t-il une petite négociation
qui sait combien combien vous arrêterez
de faire du bruit est ce que vous êtes
achetable et bien sûr que nous
visions mais c'est pas un montant de
millions
je ne parle pas comme ça moi je sais le
préjudice que j'ai je savais le salaire
que j'avais j'ai multiplié par 5 ans et
demi et je sais que j'ai été obligé de
vendre mon appartement je sais que j'ai
repris mes enfants si vous voulez aussi
parce que j'ai proposé à l'époque du
pognon pour vous faire taire
mais ça c'est ce que j'ai vu en
assistant chez l'ex drh à mon ex drh
toutes ces négociations l'an la finance
et l'entreprise qui négocier le plus
avec ses collaborateurs
pour éviter les bugs
on achète le silence
je cite dans mon désaccord entre
salariés relâche et henri ronse est pas
close de confidentialité enfin vous le
savez aussi bien que moi
[Musique]
moi je suis pas quelqu'un qui me tais je
n'ai jamais été
était comme ça et
aujourd'hui me taire pourquoi pour dire
que ce que j'ai vu je n'ai pas vu et si
je vous avais proposé du pognon à
l'époque pour vous taire
oui je ne suis pas comme ça je ne suis
ça fait pas partie de
je n'ai pas été élevé comme ça j'ai pas
du tout
ce
ce regard en revanche et là c'est pas
ubs je parle c'est monsieur sapin mais
tous nos représentants
m'aurait dit il ya trois ans et coûter
voilà pour vous remercier on vous offre
un poste dans une administration
parce qu'en plus je suis quelqu'un de
compétent je suis pas que lanceur
derrière moi je suis toujours identifiés
par rapport à ça monsieur lanceur
derrière mais non je suis j'étais
responsable marketing et communication
d'une banque d'un club de foot d'une
administration enfin j'ai fait quand
même des tonnes de choses avant dans ma
vie
c'est ça qui est important
d'avoir d'avoir une vie professionnelle
une vie sociale une vie
voilà un intérêt à vivre dans la
communauté là on est on est on est
justement radicaliser parce qu'on nous a
jetés il n'y a personne au départ on
aurait pu dire oui c'est l'industrie
financière qui se
solidarise qui se serrent les coudes
mais
sur les autres questions internet et vos
collègues point d'interrogation vous
envoyer encore certains points
d'interrogation ils se voient ils se
voilent la face point d'interrogation
alors
beaucoup de ceux qui
étaient à la banque au moment où j'étais
présente par l'actrice passe aujourd'hui
son ont eu le choix soit ils sont partis
en 2009 donc en gros ils ont eu un
chèque qui est à acheter leur silence et
sont aujourd'hui tous à la concurrence
incluent ceux qui sont mises en examen
quand même sinon on a aussi des gens mis
en examen à l'intérieur de la banque et
ceux qui sont restés ce sont ceux qui
ont eu des promotions un certain nombre
de personne d'ailleurs qui ont écrit des
attestations
que je pourrai qualifiée de mensongère
contre vous alors pas contre - contre
d'autres contre certains de mes
collègues que j'ai vu l'attestation que
j'ai lu bien évidemment
donc
les autres ceux qui sont arrivés depuis
2012 je pense que 1 ubs était obligé
quelque peu de changer ses pratiques
par définition
le nouveau président d'autant être
garant puisque c'est lui qui a la parole
dans les médias et qui assure à tout le
monde que lui jamais rien vu maintenant
ils sont tous tenus par une culture qui
est une culture que je pourrais
qualifier culture de la peur comme dans
les autres entreprises moi ce que m'ont
raconté tous les lanceurs dallaire cité
dans mon prochain bouquin et vous allez
vous n'allez pas croire ce que vous
allez lire
explique tous la même chose que
l'entreprise c'est la culture de la peur
c'est une dictature c'est soit tu suis
ce qu'on te demande de faire tu prend la
porte il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de
négociation possible j alors on va quand
on arrive sur la fin notre interview
or dernière question de la communauté
d'internet comment on fait pour
moraliser les banques pour
l'interrogation l'économie pour
interrogation alors vous n'êtes pas
obligé d'y répondre parce que bon c'est
pas votre qui ai pas entendu la fin les
banques comment on fait pour moraliser
les banques gèrent yul les colonies pour
nos interrogations
alors on est sur la moralisation moi je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure je n'aime pas
trop ce terme je parle de transparence à
la fin de mon livre là je donne
dissolution dissolution applicable
immédiatement par tous les français mais
des préconisations préconisations des
choses qu'on peut faire immédiatement et
qui vont dans le sens alors pour les
banques notamment
[Musique]
vous pouvez pas les forcer à aller
al'inverse de leurs habitudes on a
essayé avec nos affaires il aurait dû
prendre des reliques voilà on n'a pas
fermé les filiales dans les paradis
fiscaux on a et on n'a pas sorti les
guillotines
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
revenir à ce type de pratiques pour
rationaliser vous avez vous avez parlé
de brigitte à tout à l'heure en islande
en 2008 ils ont refusé de rembourser les
dettes mais d'accord les islandais ils
sont 300 me lewin en dégustant les
histoires des ils ont bien vite
dumont un train de vie important ce qui
a permis d'avoir une éducation un peu
spéciale du moins bon de berck l'été
vous avez déjà discuté qu'un néo
zélandais avec l'état quand je l'aï
rencontré birgitta c'est un peu un cap à
la guitare guitare je sais mais en a
tous stéphanie jboss à stéphanie ribot
aussi
une poétesse c'est bien quitte à aller
très engagé mais c'est là son prisme de
lecture
un islandais déjà discuté qu'un
d'islandais mais c'est vraiment 300
stations pas beaucoup
j'ai quand même un peuple qui en durcit
c'est une société d'îliens c mais pour
répondre à la question quand même
vous voyez bien que les autorités de
contrôle
elles ont été
complètement impuissante à l'école à mf
oui et de laisser faire
jusqu'au moment où nous et chez baisse
donc avait quand même plusieurs
collaborateurs concernés ont dit halte
là comment se fait-il que tous les
contrôles qui est sûrs les années
précédentes les gens n'ai jamais rien vu
donc vous voyez bien que à part le
problème est politique
quand vous avez
la déontologue d'une banque est mise en
examen pour blanchiment aggravé toute
fraude fiscale qui est nommé à la
commission des sanctions de la mfc
croyez bien qu'on ne peut pas s'en
sortir donc il faut arrêter ces mariages
elle connaît peut-être très bien les
rouages un peu comme je le
fisc inédit pas le fisc inédit mais le
kennedy qui avait été mis à l'autorité
de règlementation à la suite de la jeudi
noir pas du jeudi dont je me trompe avec
la crise demande pas fou il exactement
elle il connaissait très bien les
rouages de c2c renard et on a mis un
renard à la tête des renards pour
surveiller les renards ça peut être
aussi compris comme ça non écoutez le
patron d'ubs est ce qu'étaient les jurés
au sénat américain qui s'était rien
passé et puis qu'est finalement été
obligé de faire un rétropédalage et de
plaider coupable est aujourd'hui à la
tête de l'équivalent de la suisse non
mais si vous voulez
savait où on peut en rire on peut en
rire mais tout ça les gens ne le savent
pas et c'est pas faute de parler moi
j'ai donné je sais pas 2000 interview
depuis trois ans c'est peut-être qu'on
les jaunes ont
les gens sont des moutons pour la
plupart les moutons sont pas qu un
poisson je n'aime pas quand est ce qu
est ce que pour vous c'est le fait de ne
pas s'informer à l'heure du 21e siècle
c'est responsable de saumur oui
j'avais les cheveux sur le micro pardon
pardon j'avais
j'avais cité saint-exupéry là dessus en
disant être homme c'est être responsable
le corps d'un homme avec un grand h donc
les gens n'aiment pas ce terme
responsabilités il veut le délégué lors
responsabiliser un homme politique un
patron d'entreprise
un voisin dans le quartier qui va
s'occuper ils ne veulent pas être
concernées c'est là où il ya une pour ça
que je pense que ça va prendre encore un
peu de temps dont on est dans nos
combats depuis dix ans donc on a éveillé
certaines consciences et ceux qui
pensent comme nous et notamment la
génération des 20 ans la clé ouvre les
yeux
rejoindre notre combat mais ça va encore
être long parce que beaucoup
sont endormis en même temps peut pas
leur en vouloir non plus enfin c'est
c'est complexe bien évidemment ma
situation personnelle sera différente si
les 3000 ou sa mine qui était passé chez
ubs avaient tous dit voilà tout ce qui
était dans les banques aujourd'hui
voilà sauf que le monde ne marche pas
comme ça n'est pas chez les bisounours
justement pas du tout on va vous poser
la dernière question qu'on pose à tous
vos invités laissez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations
et dans 15 minutes le prochain direct
avec guillaume ancel a et c 15 c'est à
dire quoi quarante minutes un choix
qu'il arrive à 18 heures les enfants bon
passons
c'est les aléas du direct
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
moi j'ai élevé mes enfants
en leur disant ce qui est important
c'est votre différence ne soyez jamais
comme les autres
pensez ce que vous avez un
exprimez vous c'est pas bien ou c'est
pas mal mais c'est vous quand vous
dessinez quand vous peignez quand vous
écrivez quand vous parlez quand voilà
donc le conseil aux générations c'est
justement ça
soyez vous même mais
n'ayez pas cet esprit
[Musique]
comment dire de la pensée unique y'a pas
une vérité il n'ya pas
n'y a pas qu'une seule façon de
d'interpréter les choses tout multiple à
multi facettes et surtout quand nous un
monde globalisé donc
soyez résistants
stéphane djibo merci merci à votre
invitation au plaisir et on voudrait
encore vous dire merci
ça vient je me permets de parler toute
l'équipe merci pour ces 13 milliards
merci pour ces 600 euros écrivez chacun
voilà conseils aux générations et tous à
vos parents d'écrire un remplaçant
michel sapin de vous faire un chèque de
600 euros on vous doit tous six ans
l'état vous dois 600 euros merci
beaucoup
coupé
[Musique]
e